I
[Music]
the
remember
[Music]
do
more
why do you even have
these Christian
[Music]
yeah for
test
hello welcome welcome
we'd like to welcome you to the table
we're glad you're here this evening my
name is cat my pronouns are she and her
and we're happy that you're
here we have uh welcome to the table
class that will be meeting on August
25th at 3:00 here at the church it's be
before
service and if you would like to sign up
for that you can look at the QR code and
that's on the QR code at the on the
website
as you're able and willing will you
please stand as we enter our time for
worship now we exit the kingdom of
noise
hurry and
productivity now we
enter the the kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and Grace
now we enter Sacred
Space a space for
prayer
worship and
adoration a space to encounter Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation may love find you find
us may we all come home
thank you Cat we got sound
now it's really good to be back with you
guys I was out for the month of July and
got some good space and time away with
family um we had a good time huh yes um
but it's always good to come back and be
with community and um there's just been
reminders of what a gift this community
has been for us for our family and to
others so I hope that tonight as we're
together we can just rest in that sense
of belonging that sense of being who you
are and knowing that you are loved and
that you are seen um and this song talks
about that the fact that uh we don't
have to come with any fear with any
shame but we just enter into his
presence because he's a good God and he
loves us so Gary's going to get us
started you guys can follow him
sometimes on this
journey get lost in my
mistakes what looks to me like
weaknesses a canvas voice
strength my story isn't over my story's
just
begun fair you won't Define me that's
what my father
does fail you you won't Define me that's
does lay your burdens
down here in the father's house check
your shame at the door it ain't welcome
anymore you're in the father's house
[Music]
rival's not the end game the Journey's
where you are you never want it perfect
you just wanted my
heart and the story isn't over if the
story isn't good enough failures never
find no when the father's in the room I
said failures never find when the
father's in the room wo
wo lay your burdens down wo
wo you're in the father's house check
your shame at the door it ain't welcome
anymore wo
wo you're in the father
[Music]
house gos come
home help us find
Hope Love Is On The Moon when the
father's in the
room bris ring
wide dead come to
life love is on the when the father's in
the
room take
place cical find fa love is breaking
through when the father's in the
room jer's walls are quaking strongholds
now
shaking love is breaking through when
the father's in the room yeah yeah love
is breaking through when the father's in
the room W
wo lay your burdens down wo
wo here in the father's house check your
shame at the door it ain't welcome
anymore wo
wo you're in the father's house woo
[Music]
o there no shame
here all right you kiddos can be
dismissed to your classrooms so if y'all
will go over to those doors your
teachers will meet you and take you back
thank you so much kids team Amanda and
Becky and
Maggie and we are going to go ahead and
move into the prayers of the people so
if you guys would follow along on the
screen and read the parts that are in
red Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community in all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and the orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you to you for the vulnerable
the marginalized and those unjustly
targeted for their gender sexuality race
or other perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to
you goday
for
Angelina Jaden
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
I love you
Lord for you have delivered me
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
in the land of living
[Music]
I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
Death my feet from
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
[Music]
living and I will bless you Lord for you
heard my and cry I reach out my hand and
you save my life I will bless you Lord
for you heard my plead and the god of
Heaven turned his ear to me I will bless
you Lord for
unending love for your grace and mercy
raining down from above and I will bless
you you Lord to the very end I will call
on you as long as I may live and I love
you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
Death my feet from
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
[Music]
living first John says God is
love whoever lives in love lives in God
and God in
them this is how love is made complete
among
us we love because he first loved us
[Music]
I Love You
Lord oh your mercy never fails
me all my
days I've been hel in your
hands from the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head I will
sing of the
goodness of
God I love your
voice you have led me through the
fire in dark
you are close like no
other I've known you as a
father I've known you as a
[Music]
friend I have lived in the
goodness of
[Music]
God and until my life you have been
faithful
[Music]
and all my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I
am I will
sing of the
goodness of
[Music]
God I love you you
Lord oh your mercy never fails
me and my
days I've been held in your
hands from the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head I will
sing of the
goodness of God
all my
life all my life you have been
[Music]
faithful and all my life you have been
so so
good every breath I
am I will
see of the
goodness of
God sing your Mercy's running after your
goodness is running after it's running
after
me your goodness is running after it's
running after me with my life laid down
I Surrender now I'll give you
everything your goodness is running
after it's running after me
home alive you have been
faithful oh my life you have been so
so with every breath that I
[Music]
a I will
sing of the
goodness of God
all my
life oh my life you have been
than oh my life you have been so so good
oh with every breath that I am
a I will sing all the goodness of God
oh I will sing of the goodness of
God I will
sing of the
goodness of
God
Jesus we're able to sing words like that
not because we haven't known
pain not because things are always going
well not because we somehow are able to
escape all our Temptations and our vices
our destructive
behaviors not even because we've always
felt close to
[Music]
you but because in my
soul I
know that I was created in love Love by
a God who saw us who knows us who calls
us by
name and that God does not abandon
us he doesn't leave us he doesn't
forsake
us and just like your word says there's
nothing that can separate us from the
love of
God it is always available
it is always
sure it is always
steadfast so God we look to your
love we look to your goodness
[Music]
tonight and we see it woven through our
story in the dark days in our loss in
our pain our confus confusion our
doubt God and we believe that it will
continue to carry us
through it will continue to bring us
back
home thank you for who you are in the
way that you have loved us laying your
life
down redeeming us forgiving us
saving
us it's in Jesus name we
pray
amen would you guys welcome the people
around you and then Brett will get us
started on our message
all
right
well we are few but we are Mighty
tonight I know saxi Garland schools are
kicking off tomorrow so um I imagine
that's what it is but um yeah all that
to say glad to be with you all welcome
welcome here to the table um my name is
Brett I yeah you all know that okay so I
don't have to do that that whole thing I
don't have
yeah um it would be really funny if
someone snuck in the left or something
um yeah so so welcome into the space and
uh that also includes those join us
online love you all lots and um yeah
just really glad glad to be with you in
this space and um and and really I'm
excited for this series I'm I was
thinking back on like sermons and series
I've done I don't know if I've ever done
one on The Parables so certainly not at
the table I don't think so that is the
series we're in The Parables of Jesus
and uh walking our way through some of
these and uh these were these short
stories that are fairly unique
to um Christ they seem to be uh like in
essence they're not there's not if you
look through the scriptures there's not
like ah the tradition of the parable you
know and Jesus is like redoing it or no
no there's not I mean there's stories in
the Bible but not these kind of short
Punchy you know one paragraph kind of
two paragraph kind of stories um so this
seems to be something Jesus Jesus um
that kind of originated within him and
uh which means you know hey we would be
wise to think deeply on them you know
take some time to reflect on these
stories and um what they might you know
what they might mean for us so um that's
kind of what we're doing so with that in
mind the title of my message tonight is
The Parables of the treasure and the
Pearl um so these are actually two
Parables but you know they're like
really short and you can see the the
common theme so we'll be in Matthew chap
13 uh:
44-46 it reads the Kingdom of Heaven is
like treasure hidden in a field when a
man found it he hid it again and then in
his Joy went and sold all he had which
is pretty extreme I think you'll agree
all he had and bought that field again
the Kingdom of Heaven it's like a a
merchant looking for fine pearls when he
found one of Great Value he went away
and sold everything he had and bought
it I've been thinking about what is it
um we desire I think this these both of
these parables are stories of desire
right I mean this is like even kind of
archetypal like you know the treasure
and there's all these stories you know
whether it's like pirate stories or you
know just look looking for the treasure
and that that's kind of the what I think
a little bit going on here there's this
kind of image of you know our longings
our desires and I was listening to a a
different um kind of spiritual teacher
named Rupert spirit and he was asking um
we kind of pointing out like uh you know
it's interesting if you kind of
interrogate your desires like if I to
ask um you know what is it you
want there would of course be like a lot
of different answers and even if I ask
not just kind of like oh like list your
top 100 but you know like know what's
the thing that maybe the top three
things you want above all other things
you know there would of course be like a
lot of different answers uh you know
some of it's can be like maybe money
related I'd love to double double my
income you know or I just I just wish I
had a new job or um it can even be kind
of you know uh relational perhaps you
know I wish I wish I had a a partner or
you know romantic relationship or uh
more close friends or you know whatever
like we just we have all of these you
know desires and and things we we want
and we seek and um spir he pointed out
he said you know it can seem like
they're all different on the surface you
know it's like this person wants you
know Daryl wants one thing and Maggie
wants another and you know and so on um
but he said if you look you know beneath
the surface and you ask someone um
why why do you want that thing that
possession that relationship that you
know experience you know whatever uh if
you ask why it's it's almost always a
desire for you know choose your words
here but something like you know peace
happiness joy you know that that sense
of like well-being that that in essence
the reason we want the thing is so that
we have the feeling it gives us us you
know the the kind of we hope lasting
kind of experience of that for example
um if I were to say like hey there's a
job I know of if your desire is like to
you know double your income this year
this job and you know you're a lock for
it it's yours there is just one catch
though I know it's so stressful you I
can almost guarantee you will be
hospitalized with anxiety this year if
you take that job you know you'd likely
be hesitant all of a sudden and I say
who why like this is your desire this is
the thing you said above all things you
wanted to double your income you're like
well I didn't only want that you know I
mean like in essence well I wanted the
feeling the experience the happiness the
peace that I thought the income would
give you know would give me and so on um
in essence you might say that kind of in
our own ways like we're all on this
journey we're all searching for this
treasure in a field this this pearl of
great price um those possessions
experiences relationships that that we
think will bring us you know they'll be
the
thing they'll be the thing and of course
over the years though um we learn a
little bit you know sometimes we get
like very disappointed by something that
we thought was going to be the thing and
then it turns out not to be you know so
you might say that our search gets more
and more refined um perhaps we could say
as we learn what the treasure is not
what the Pearl is not you know I think
we can all agree when we're perhaps
younger we have like kind of um maybe
simplistic or kind of even materialistic
dreams usually for what that is going to
be you know what that what's really
going to to satisfy but over you know
over the years um we learn and we often
I think learn from experience I remember
talking a few months ago about how
sometimes we just have to learn a thing
for ourselves you know it's like we can
know it intellectually like I had to go
through this with money where it's like
I knew I mean I think maybe just being
raised in church and such like I knew
the right answer like money's not going
to do it it's not going to fill the void
you know like I me it can don't get me
wrong it can help you know sort of
stress that money can relieve but it's
sort of you've seen maybe those graphs
about money where the the happiness
curve flattens you know what I mean so
at first I mean if you're like dead
broke and you're stressed about money
and then you get some you're like oh my
gosh no my life's better you know but
what happens is it kind of levels you
know so it doesn't just go off into
Infinity just better and better and
better and better and better better and
better so that a you know a billionaire
is a billion times happier than anyone
like no no right it just kind of goes
woo and it just kind of evens off now I
could show that we could like teach that
in kids ministry for example you know
hey kids here's the money happiness
curve you know notice it doesn't go up
to Infinity it flattens in the US around
80k a year you know like it's there this
sort of and they could hear that right
intellectually okay interesting
statistics does that mean that in their
own little
hearts that that suddenly that kind of
longing dream like right in essence no
this is true for all of us true for me
like we kind of have to we have to learn
we have to experience it in our bones
you know of like in essence getting the
thing that we thought was the treasure
experiencing the thrill which it is you
know just like whatever it is for you
you know getting that thrill and you're
like riding the high you know and then
you kind of come off it and then kind of
realize like oh so I'm I'm still
me same problems
same heart and mind you know as we
talked about last week like just oh I
just have more money now you know
whatever the the thing is and uh so now
at that point that's kind of a fork in
the road for many of us some people what
they do is they double down they say oh
I know the issue it was not enough money
you know so then it's like I need to 10x
this you know what okay and then they're
off on their own Journey for the next 20
years trying to okay
others keep switching you know so like
okay well it wasn't that it's this no
it's not that it's this it's not that
it's this it's the you know we're kind
of switching right but the whole time I
don't I don't say that in a way of
shaming because I think this is part of
the journey that we're kind of learning
learning okay what the treasure is not
what the treasure is not and again
learning it experientially not just in a
book you know or whatever it's okay it's
sinking
in and um
what happens okay so we we keep going on
this journey at some point and this kind
of brings us specifically into the
context here in church I think we um we
make what I'll call the religious
turn which is where I want to focus um
for quite a bit on what the treasure is
not in kind of Christian religious terms
and then towards the end we'll talk a
little bit about what I think it is um
because this becomes I think its own
little trap you know that in essence we
say oh yeah okay not about those
materialistic things and desires and
more you know whatever fancy this and
that and no no okay it's we get kind of
religiously you know more refined
answers um and people get yeah really
into um religious type type things and
this often again follows on the heels of
being in incredibly
disappointed by what the broader culture
said was going to be the answer you know
a one more quick thought on that
actually there's an a wonderful example
of the the kind of broader culture you
see this every four years with the
Olympics did youall see this little
expose on Caleb dressle the
swimmer where he talked about his 2020
Tokyo experience so this is an example
before the religious term that you can
see him kind of starting to make a
little you know a little um change
himself so he went to Tokyo right and
had like all the success in the world I
don't know if youall remember a few
years back but like he was just killing
it I mean it's like every time he hit
the pool he he won Caleb drussell Caleb
I mean just over and over like gu just
and he's handsome youall see these
images like geez this guy what's you
know and so he's just he's wi I mean
it's incredible but he
shared that not only even after but even
like during the Olympics he
had um this kind of gnawing within him
and is it fading are we okay um where he
he felt like a failure basically because
he said he had this he calls it the
inner critic the voice in his head that
said so he wins gold in like all the
events he ERS but he didn't get the
world record in the 100 free and that's
what the voice told him his head said
failed you didn't have a good
Olympics you own you set the record in
the 50 free but you didn't get the world
record in the 100 free
and suddenly this was like a catastrophe
for him but a good catastrophe in the
sense of he had to go through this
experience to realize
oh so this isn't going to work this
isn't going to like it's not like I'm
going to get enough Awards right okay so
so that's kind of the way of the world
right we're just chasing these external
things if all they have all right and
then we we make what I'm going to call
the religious
turn and um I do think this can be a
this is a good turn
because maybe if in the past we're not
even like searching in the right you
know we're not even in the right state
so to speak
like we're in the right County you know
we're kind of like okay we're we're
narrowing down we're getting there
um the the trick
is we we we get religious and the people
around us
say you've got it
you found the treasure in the field you
have the pearl of great price isn't it
great and you're like yes you know but
you're but even here you're kind of
having to journey
into um what exactly does this mean and
this is where I think there's um I'm
going to call these kind of I'm using
the term Pitfall maybe this is a little
negative I could also if I wanted to
make it more gentle I could call these
religious side quests anyone's into like
video games and you have like your main
kind of quest you know but then you have
the side quest you just want to go off
and do like a thing and kind of like I
want to get more Awards I want to do you
know these are religious side quests but
I'm going to call them like they can be
dangerous because they can be tremendous
um
distractions like in essence you your
inches might even say your inches from
the treasure like it's right there and
again you have the information
intellectually right like God Christ
like okay so you're right there but then
you get like lost
in the side quests so all right we'll
call this religious Pitfall number one
the false Treasure of superiority and
pride as I Revel in my religious
tradition Doctrine or Orthodox
belief um what happens here this is I'm
this was one I know well um because I
have and continue to slip into this at
times like this is where
uh like for example one way it
manifested in my life was with with a
love of arguing with people online about
Theology and feeling very good about
myself
indeed that I was right and they're just
idiots you know like they're they're not
they can't keep up you know I mean
they're not smart they haven't read the
right books they don't have the right
theology they don't have the you know
um what can happen here I I would say
it's it can get very
abstract you know so it's it's literally
it's it's ideal land you know I mean
you're kind of living in idea land and
arguing with others um of course it can
manifest a little bit differently um
some people um maybe it's even just
individual personal where they're kind
of off in their own world this at least
for inogram fives I might be
interpreting this one through the lens
of an inogram 5 who's like very lost in
my head you know books and ideas it
might look different I can think of
maybe even those who get kind of lost in
like church like um relational in the
sense of like trying to be thought well
of by people in the church like this is
now a new community I'm a part of and I
want to be like someone esteemed you
know I want to I want to get into like
that position where everyone's like wow
you are very important you are very
important to us in this community and so
your whole kind of religious life life
you know I mean becomes about becoming
that important person and right can you
see where this this it gets strange like
suddenly they're like why are you
here you know what I mean why are you
here and it's
like different re side
questing you know falling into these
pitfalls kind of losing track of the the
treasure the Pearl um so right so this
is one um a second one the false
Treasure of seeking whizbang religious
highs and
experiences uh this can look this is
even I was thinking kind of outside of
like even Christianity um I think there
can sometimes
um maybe like right now for example
psychedelics is big in the culture or
kind of making a comeback and I do think
actually there's like therapeutic like I
get some of the research are doing
around that you know in a kind of
certain settings and such I could see
I'm not trying to I don't know just rant
against it or something but I do think
this is again where you can be kind of a
side quest like this kind of like you
wouldn't believe the mystical experience
I had you wouldn't believe the crazy
this and that I had you know what I mean
and there's like various forms of this
you get kind of more woow woo kind of
world you know and there's kind of that
form of it of like I'm gaining occult
Powers you know or I'm getting this and
that and I'm or in kind of more you know
christiany language like I'm seeing
demons everywhere there was there's a
spirit in here you know I mean it's like
there's this kind of constant need for
like the incredible the ecstatic the
remarkable the you wouldn't believe you
know it just it has to be kind of yeah
you know this kind of level of uh energy
and such I have an example of this I
went um there's a church I was involved
and previously they had something they
called encounter weekends
in these encounter weekends these were
like they was a Pentecostal charismatic
kind of roots for the the thing so I
should say on upside like people had
like real breakthroughs at these
weekends I saw some good fruit from it
was incredible stuff but also it became
this kind of thing I'm describing where
it's like can't wait till my next
encounter can't wait till my next
encounter weekend people started
referring to themselves as encounter
Junkies like they would say like I'm an
encounter junk can't like so every
quarter there was an encounter and there
were people there they've been to like
20 encounters you know just ready for
the next holy spirit High you know
um this is not not coincidentally a lot
of those folks did have a background
with like substance abuse kind of stuff
right so what happened there's certain
emotions feelings kind of an inner world
going on and they' kind of found a new
way to distract
themselves from that some of that real
work that Journey you know now it's
using God to kind of like you know um
this this becomes yeah this becomes a
huge huge issue um third religious
Pitfall the false Treasure of religious
misery
now um in exchange for heaven
later I think this this is sort of an
example where it's like um the treasure
the
Pearl oh no no no no no no you're that's
not for now no no no you're confused
that's heaven heaven when you die God
doesn't care about your happiness your
peace your sense of joy and
contentedness with life right now no no
God doesn't care about your happiness he
cares about your Holiness and that's
what this life's about it's like
spiritual boot camp and we're just
living for that day you know and you can
see where kind of everything gets geared
sometimes these two the point number two
and three are kind of like to Waring
camps within Christian theology you know
where the one group is kind of like no
it's all here and now but it's all very
kind of like you know and then there's
the other group that's like in reaction
to that and they're like that is
ridiculous we are going to get serious
about Christian discipleship and you
there's this kind of um a kind of
joylessness I mean honestly kind of a
spiritual depression that can kind of
settle over people as they sort of start
to give up um hope and in a way like
hope of
really knowing god I think
connecting
um yeah it's it's
really well I I think what what's
happened here is you might say this is a
kind of a version of Christianity that's
lost touch with its source I think of um
John 10:10 Jesus says the thief comes
only to steal kill and destroy I have
come that they may have life and have it
to the
full life right it's not I've come that
they may go to heaven one day you know
um but it's life it begins here and now
and yes into the future right into the
life to come but it's life right here
and now or I think of uh John 154 abide
in me Jesus says As I abide in you just
as the branch cannot bear fruit by
itself in uh unless it abides in the
vine neither can you unless what unless
you abide in me me what's that saying
there's this sense of living in
God living in
God right the context of these passages
is not pie in the sky when you die you
know this life is so miserable and
horrible it's terrible to be a Christian
but boy it's all going to pay off you
know um maybe globally this might be the
most popular not just in Christian faith
this can be other religious Traditions
too that that end up kind of pushing off
everything to um to heaven
okay so uh so what is the what is it
then what is this this treasure this
this Pearl you know if it's not exactly
synonymous with um you know just
religion or just even Christianity
whatever exactly that means and that's a
big old word you know has meant a lot of
things um what what what's going on here
this is where I have found um the
contemplative tradition the mystical
tradition of Christianity so so helpful
uh
because I
think it kind of names that some of our
challenge is that we've all been caught
up in an illusion of
sorts that in essence we have this
experience of being incredibly separated
from God this sense of Separation now
what they point out is that the
separation SE ation is not
real but the sense of
Separation oh
friends that's
real and and what they name is this is
why we
ache this is why we run around chasing
1,000 things trying like to fill the
void like I need I need something I need
something
but at at some point we we settle down
and we start to get just a we call like
an
inlan just a just a taste of the god
we've come to know in Christ again not
just in like words and ideas and
abstractions and and theologies and such
but in this this kind of heart mind way
might sum it up by saying that God in
Christ restores us to a sense of
connectedness and
Union God in Christ restores us to a
sense of connectedness and Union that is
the true
treasure it's a union found in Stillness
yes it's a union found in
silence it's a union found in the very
depths of our
being and as the parable says
when you get even just a taste of this
what do you do well I I love the parable
for its all
inness isn't that the language here in
Matthew like it's like you start to get
a taste of that and you're like oh my
gosh I found it like I I can't believe
it and you go what do you do you go all
in on that now notice this is different
than just sort of all in on your
religion you know what I mean like in
that that kind of way where it's again
there's a lot of pitfalls here but it's
it's all in on that sense of I mean
another word we could use is love that
sense of love that sense of
connectedness that that um
healing uh Touch Of God these are all
metaphors for that this sense of Union
and we get taste of that and we go all
in on that
and and it is true that in a way um it
costs us
everything like not literally in the
sense of boy just watch out your life
just falls apart you know like if you
got a job well that's gone you know
family uhuh you know um not kind of at
that literal level but there is in in
the heart and mind level
it it's true there is a profound sense
of
surrender that we're invited into where
it's like we didn't even realize all
these areas we were just grasping
grasping grasping grasping like just
holding holding controlling controlling
controlling and there is
something very
profound um internally that we are
invited into and maybe from the outside
looking in it could look like a
sacrifice
you know it could look like wow you're
giving things up you know but it's more
like things are falling off us things
are being let go of uh being surrendered
which is why if you were to ask the man
in the parable like oh my gosh you've
really given up a lot and you just look
like you're like you're crazy because
it's not that he gave up a lot why he's
like I got the treasure I got the
Pearl and I mean in essence like what
could be more profound than God you know
like that sense of Union connectedness
what what could be more important than
that and so I think that's what this
journey is about I think this is what
we're being invited into week after week
after week but again it's something we
do communally but at another level there
is something somewhat individual about
it in the sense of we're here for one
another we're we're supporting each
other we're on the path towards Christ
but it it can't be like we'll just all
do this for you you know like there no
there there is a uh still a sense of
I'll just call it maybe
responsibility you know where we kind of
have to own like okay
God you've invited me into this profound
Union and but I've got to step into it
I've got to by Grace embrace it and and
so when I think of uh the table and
that's my kind of my heart and my prayer
is that everyone here who
seeks that great promise of Jesus that
all who seek Will Truly
find and man may we be a a community of
seekers and Finders wers as we pursue
this this treasure this Pearl in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit amen so as we uh come to the
table of the Lord tonight as we take in
the body of Christ and the bread the
blood of Christ in the
wine may it be a little a little taste I
mean even the word communion it's it's
co- Union connectedness
relatedness and so my prayer is as you
come forward you would would have that
that little taste of um a sense of
connectedness to the one who made you
who knows you who loves you and pursues
you uh even here and now so um you all
know how we do
communion so we're just going to do it
that way we always do so all right um
yeah love youall Lots so this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you who
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
for
if you guys want to stand with us we're
going to close with Graves into Gardens
and
um if you guys want to sing these words
with the treasure message that Brett
just gave in
mind just um acknowledging acknowledging
that we've all you know spent time if
not our currently spending time looking
for that treasure that fix but trying to
turn our eyes towards God and the way
that his goodness truly does satisfy
better than anything
else I search the
world but he couldn't F
me me praise Treasures that fade are
never enough
[Music]
and you came
along and put me back
together and every desire is now
satisfied hear in your
[Music]
love oh there's
nothing better than you or there's
nothing
than you Lord there's
nothing nothing is better than
[Music]
you I know it's
true I'm Not
[Music]
Afraid show you my
weakness my faes and flaws Lord you seen
them all and you still call me
friend cuz the god of the
[Music]
mountain he's the god of the
valley there's not a place your mercy
and Grace on find me
again oh there's
nothing better than than you there's
nothing better than you Lord there's
nothing nothing is better than
[Music]
you oh there's
nothing better than you Lord there's
nothing nothing is better
[Music]
you you turn morning to
dancing you give Beauty for
ases you and shame into
Glory you're the only one who
cares you turn morning to
dancing you give Beauty for
ases you turn shame into
Glory you're the only one who
can you turn Graves into Gard
[Music]
you turn bones into
armies you turn SE into
highways you're the only one who
car you're the only one who
car you're the only one who car
[Music]
so much for being here this evening if
you are new uh and
visiting and if you would like to fill
out um an information card on the table
or scan the QR code we would love to uh
find out about you and answer any
questions that you have and say well
welcome and please come
back if you are in need of a prayer a
hug or just any general support you can
find me after the service I would love
to be there for
you here at the table we are a committed
we are committed to creating an
inclusive Christ centered community that
touches lives and generosity is a key
component component component excuse me
I can't talk to that mission if you'd
like to join us in supporting the work
financially you can scan the QR code or
on the screens or on the lob in the
lobby or go to the website at the table
tx.org
all right I would like to send you um
into your week with this
blessing you can hold out your hands in
a posture to receive
or just open your hearts to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God that is true on your best day and
that is true on your worst day so as you
go into this week ahead with it's yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and
go filled with God's holy spirit and a
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact
with be
blessed have a good week find your
treasure
and we hope to see you back next week
good
[Music]
night oh there's
nothing better than you oh there's
nothing nothing is better than
[Music]
you oh there's nothing
better than you Lord there's
nothing better than you Lord there's
nothing nothing is better than
[Music]
you I know it's
true I know it's true more
more I know it's true
good job team that was great nice job
everyone I felt last one felt good